My life is hell.
I want to get out of Chino.
Listen to me.
I haven't learned much in my life but I know one thing.
Dreams don't come true.
He's right, not in Chino.
Ryan, you're a clever kid.
Have you thought about your future?
In Chino, you don't have dreams.
Dreams don't come true.
He stole a car and you brought him home?
She's so beautiful.
Who are you?
Anyone you want.
Who's that?
He's cute!
I don't really know.
Well, I plan to find out.
Welcome to the O.C.!
If I ever see you here again, you're dead. Dead!
I don't know what to say.
Tonight was fantastic.
You were totally there for me.
You were like Brad Pitt in Fight Club!
Maybe you could teach me how to fight...
...and next time, we'll win!
Welcome to the dark side.